it's the kremlin's annual show of
strength
11 000 russian troops and more than 100
military vehicles paraded through
moscow's red square marking victory day
the anniversary of the soviet defeat of
nazi germany but this year the world was
watching to hear what the russian
president would say about his war in
ukraine
you are fighting for the motherland
vladimir putin said so that no one
forgets the lessons of world war ii
there was no place in the world for
executioners and nazis defending his
invasion putin claimed without evidence
that ukraine was seeking nuclear weapons
and that nato was planning to attack
russian-speaking communities in the east
but what's perhaps most remarkable is
what putin didn't say
he didn't declare mass mobilization
he didn't threaten
to use nuclear weapons
he didn't declare
victory putin's former speechwriter says
the president appeared a weakened figure
i see in the speech that they are ready
to retreat
it's it wouldn't be a big exaggeration
to say that this speech has an
invitation to negotiating table putin
obviously he refused to escalate the
situation this is an invitation
putin has long used victory day to
reinforce the idea that russia is a
great superpower it's military unmatched
but that image now stands in sharp
contrast to its error-riddled invasion
of ukraine
we have seen the russian military for
what it is and it is probably at best
a second-tier military
even this russian army veteran one of
the leaders of russia's annexation of
crimea in 2014 has been posting videos
like
this claiming it will be impossible for
russia to win in ukraine under what he
calls its incompetent leadership but
these days that level of criticism is
rare
over the past couple of months thousands
of russians who've dared to condemn the
war have been arrested they are not that
much scared of
police the head of russia's main
independent polling firm says the vast
majority of russians claim to support
their president and his so-called
special military operation
do you think russians genuinely support
this operation or are they just afraid
to say that they don't if it is
fear then this is a fear of being not in
line with the rest of the nation the
perception of this
special operation is this is a combat
with united states or nato
now back in march those opinion polls
showed support for the war in ukraine at
over 80 percent but that has dropped
several points since then and those
russian pollsters predict that the
longer the war drags on the more
unpopular it and putin will become donna
jeff you were at victory day
celebrations in red square a few years
ago what was your impression of the
differences between then and now
yeah well back in 2017 there were other
foreign leaders in attendance today not
even vladimir putin's closest allies
showed up and after the event back in
2017 we were also able to interview
ordinary russians some of whom were
openly critical of their president but
that openness appears to have vanished
almost overnight it is much more
difficult to get people in russia to
speak with us now some of them say
that's because we're a enemy network
from an enemy country but others say
it's simply because it's not worth the
risk of 15 years in prison
donna even calling it a war is a crime
now jeff semple in toronto thanks